I put that hat on it's just look what's
going to happen it's just not going to
work talk about Amish
your tilt game is off
we went through this a long time ago
when you had to do the 125th Street
shows at the Apollo now you got to tilt
that hat if you're going to tilt it tilt
that hat man what he tilt it in one way
you had the perfect long face like me
yeah you gotta wear it you gotta wear
the hat yeah
this is too much of a pop no no no this
looks like I've been in a train accident
no you would know that's too much that's
too much the 1930s way too much of a
tilt right there all right all right all
right I gotta get it back up again back
up right there yeah right here right
there yeah okay but you gotta act like
you gotta believe it if you don't
believe it I will never will
reject you I am not gonna believe this
this is never gonna work for me see
that's the kind of hat on you if you
don't wear it right that hat will
intentionally get blown away by the wind